right now we've just completed some
research actually so it's a very timely
question for Mme mid-market customers
across the UK and when I say mid market
I mean businesses with between 200 and
2,000 employees and the mood is mixed
fifty percent of businesses feel
optimistic which is a concern that only
half of them do with the key things that
they're really looking for are some
clarity around brexit skills are a huge
challenge for them and also technology
as well being quite a challenge so the
mood is next for our clients directly
we're not seeing brexit impact on a
tangible basis but what's been brilliant
this morning is hearing more talk around
growing the industrial strategy and
globalization and perhaps one of the
biggest insights in the research that
we've done is that 17% of business
turnover comes from exports which of
course suggests that there is a huge
opportunity there to increase and in
fact a figure that you might like to
hear is that if businesses just increase
that turnover exporting by 5% that would
add 4 billion pounds to the economy of
the UK productivity is a massive issue
right now you're seeing much evidence of
your customers investing more to improve
their productivity so it's really
interesting because productivity of
course depends on getting the right
skills in and the right people within
business and that is a huge challenge
but we are seeing more and more
businesses look to artificial
intelligence to actually decide how they
can use data they've got in their
business to improve their productivity
and business specifically I would say in
the last six months are actually turning
to look at this a lot more
and again that's featured here this
morning at the conference as well you
mentioned exports just now do you see
much evidence of Britain remaining as
great an exporting nation Post brexit as
it is currently so I think as far as
exports are concerned what businesses
really need is clarity actually to
ensure that they can still continue to
use the supply chains that they use now
and that red tape won't be increased as
a result of brexit so I think the most
important thing is that we all work with
government as well to ensure that
regulation doesn't change or have a
negative impact on
businesses being able to export with
with businesses outside of Europe